today on stick to football we are
breaking the NFL down maybe looking at
the week that was also fixing the
Cincinnati Bengals yes it is draft
season for a couple teams we're gonna
start looking at the roster moves
everyone needs to make and our good
friend Jim naggy comes back on the show
to talk about the 2020
Reese's Senior Bowl Connors with me in a
killer shirt which you can see if you
check us out on bleach reports YouTube
page just look for the stick to football
playlist Connor welcome in buddies good
see you that's right man good to see you
I know it hasn't been too long as we had
an awesome week down in Dallas at the
Red River Rivalry have to be careful
what you call it these days and man eyes
ahead we're gonna get to the London
event in a second but our Alabama LSU
tailgate on November 9th at the quad
officially Matt that might be the game
of the year if you play outright it is
the game of the you guys think I think
we're gonna see one versus two I'm very
excited for this game we actually like
you said we nail down the details over
the weekend so we will be out there the
game as time has not been officially
announced by the SEC we have been told
to expect a 2:30 kick so we'll be out
there at 7 a.m. bright and early like
Connor said on the quad we're tailgate
spot number 133 we'll have a big white
tent you'll see the stick to football
guys in there a lot of beer a lot of
food so come check it out again these
tailgates are free just stop by start
hanging out with us will be giving away
kuzey stickers like we always do so look
for an exact time but for now you can go
ahead and plan on being on the quad as
early as they will let us be probably at
7 a.m. Saturday morning November 9th
let's go sorry no for our listeners
overseas we do have some details for you
the venue nothing official yet we're
gonna get to that probably on the
Friday's show unless something changes
in the middle of this show but Saturday
October 26th in London that is the day
of college football I know for a lot of
people in London it is the day of what
you call football but we're gonna be
having an event locally in London
Saturday October 26 you can expect that
event to be in the afternoon around 3 or
4 o'clock so for everybody in that area
we just want to confirm with you we're
gonna be there we're gonna have an event
we'll probably do something Sunday as
well but sad
we'll be the day you want to have an
open schedule in the afternoon and we
will announce the venue that we are
really excited about very soon so we
hope to see everyone there yep yeah
absolutely it's gonna be an amazing trip
to London I'm excited as someone who's
never been there so also tweet us your
tips for that all right let's get into
the news Zac Brown not the former
country singer the former linebacker for
the Philadelphia Eagles before the
Eagles played the Vikings he said Kurt
cousin sucks which I would have agreed
with until week five but week five
cousins and Thielen hooked back up and
then last week Stefon Diggs and cousins
hooked back up the Vikings have been an
unstoppable offensive juggernaut since
really getting called onto the carpet by
everyone in the world
well Zac Brown ran his mouth after the
game he was like I don't want to talk
about it well now he is a former member
of the Eagles
Howie Roseman cut Zac Brown on Monday
which I don't know how much of it's tied
to his play how much of his tied to his
comments but he's gone
I mean God what an awful weekend that's
how you have a bad one if you're anyone
in any profession is when you talk your
[ __ ] and then you lose your job
somewhere Kirk Cousins is smiling now I
will say this I think Zac Brown will be
picked up pretty quickly in this league
I don't think he'll be on the market
very long and to me Matt it's probably a
situation where it was a mix of both he
probably wasn't playing at a Pro Bowl
level and it probably didn't help that
he created somewhat of a distraction
that makes the team look foolish in the
end and the Eagles with a pretty harsh
reaction but guess what the NFL is not
friendly to people very often no it's
really not it is definitely a what have
you done for me League and Zach Brown
all he did was put a spotlight on his
team they then got blew up the Eagles
reeling a little bit which a lot of the
NFL is but one team that's not your team
the New York Jets we were in Dallas over
the weekend and so many cowboys fans
were giving you hell because other Jets
are gonna get game over by the Cowboys
not so fast and really not so fast on a
lot of things not so fast on Jason
Garrett's job being safe
not so fast on Kellen Moore being this
offensive genius who's gonna be a future
head coach I am here to officially try
get Lincoln Riley to be the next head
coach the Dallas Cowboys because my
Texas Longhorns can't beat him so if
Lincoln could go to Dallas that would
make me very very happy I'm with you all
the way and to be fair on the show the
Cowboys were without both starting
tackles Amari Cooper got hurt in the
first quarter but everybody has injuries
in the NFL guys I mean the Jets have
been without their probably best
defensive player and CJ Mosley they're
starting tight end Chris Herndon these
things happen they lost Quincy and knew
and well already so people get banged up
in the NFL and the Jets went out and won
the game really on the back of Sam darn
'old and credit to Adam GaSe who I've
been critical of and then everybody in
the world has been critical of call the
good game was aggressive didn't ease
Sam's Arnold back in who would have
never wanted that in the first place
they threw the ball down the field
they went four points before the half
and got six they went for the kill shot
at the end that got them in field goal
range that ultimately won them the game
as they won by two points and Greg
Williams kept his foot on the gas and
kept blitzing because he knows his
corners can't cover anyone but more
importantly in this situation to the
Cowboys end of things a team that was
picked by many as a Super Bowl contender
started out the year very hot good play
calling by Kellen Moore a really good
start by dak Prescott the ground game
was moving the defense looks good they
were healthy you're right Matt they need
more from the head coach they did not
get off the bus at MetLife you're ready
to play they did not get pressure on a
quarterback that it was just back from
an illness for a long time the Jets were
without pieces on the offensive line
shuma Doga was making his second start
and had to you know really play start it
right tackle Brandon shale came in
because Calvin Beecham got hurt so the
Jets were with to backup offensive
tackles no Coletti assembly and the
Cowboys really didn't do a great job of
getting after the quarterback so there's
a lot of problems across the board for
what I think is a very talented football
team no it is then I was I was actually
happy for Adam GaSe I mean people who've
listened to the show since the summer
will remember I actually liked that
higher because of Sam darn old I said I
thought darn 'old a case were really
good fit together the case would know
how to use Sam that Sam fit really well
in his offense so for one week to see
that happen does look good
also see Robbie Anderson get
incorporated that is huge I also thought
that really this week Gregg Williams had
his best game as a defensive coordinator
with the New York just great
the timing of the Blitz call us with
Jamal Adams were very very good down the
stretch
Marcus may and Brian Poole book played
really well in the secondary so for the
Jets for a week everything was perfect
and I think if you're Dallas you know a
lots gonna be made of the fact that like
no one wants to slap hands with Jason
Garrett after they score there is
something to that I really believe that
I think you can look at Atlanta I think
you look at Pittsburgh thing you look at
Dallas right now as teams where the
messages may be gotten stale so you know
we always say it yeah we could see a
refresh really at the head coach
position not that those teams lack
talent just you you almost need new
leadership you need a new voice in the
building to get things done my team
however oh my lord one of my teams well
said what am i a t-shirt um when we
picked preseason win losses playoffs I
thought I was a little too high on the
49ers I had them at eight and eight like
it's you if we stay healthy I'm an
eighth Nate could be good you know
there's some young guys or good players
but you got to stay healthy well they
haven't stayed healthy and they're still
good they are undefeated the only
undefeated team in the NFC again and
they are doing it because that defense I
think it is the most fun defense to
watch in the NFL right now with how
attacking they are Nick Bosa is able to
do so many things on the edge in a large
part thanks to what happens with
DeForest Buckner drawing attention in
the middle Arik Armstead is finally
living up to his potential Dee Ford is
flashing the Niners are just fast
defensively and they are very aggressive
it makes them a blast to watch I like
watching the Patriots defense - I think
Stephane Gilmore's the best corner and
football right now but the Niners
they're getting it done one thing that I
like about this team they're doing it
differently every week like they can out
score you or they can shut you down
though rush for 300 yards or it's a game
where Kyle Shanahan after the the game
will let his defensive coordinator do
the press conference because he's been
that impressive calling the defense so I
think our the Niners for real yeah I
definitely they are but also it's
encouraging that they're showing they
can win in a couple different ways yeah
picked them to win six games and they've
won five out of five so far so things
are looking good for the Niners right
now and I think Matt you know things are
going well when Solomon Thomas is
getting in on the action
I mean Salomon Thomas with the big sack
in this game like you said whether it's
Nick Bosa that front seven is giving is
really doing a lot of favors for the
secondary Richard Sherman is still
playing at a high level I know he's been
banged up as he gets older but still
Richard Sherman is still playing at a
high level for this team but across the
board yeah I like what you said about
them doing things differently whether
it's you know Mike McDaniel
Kyle Shanahan scheming up the run game
when they have to making life easier on
Jimmy G George kiddo being one of maybe
the best tight end in the NFL honestly I
would have that conversation right now
that George Kittel is the best tight end
in the NFL I agree yeah teams that win
in different ways often go far in the
postseason New England is the master of
doing this they are ready on all three
phases of the football game whether it's
special teams defense or offense because
if one or two areas are lacking the
other can pick those two up and I think
we're seeing that with San Francisco
right now and that's a great point by d
ford i think d ford has you know been a
inconsistent player at times and he was
phenomenal in this game and has been
pretty good for pennies on the dollar as
an acquisition this year for the Niners
yeah he really has been and I think you
can look at even like Quan Alexander was
not an inexpensive sign me but he's been
very good Fred Warner's been good a
second year player so I still think they
have a need a corner I wouldn't be
surprised if they made a move for a
receiver at the deadline not like an AJ
Green but just to get some depth of the
receiver position but for now they look
to be set real quick before we go into
our first break the Dolphins the Bengals
still have not won a game the Redskins
finally win one
yeah that's win one so we have to
windless teams still and that is the
Bengals and the Dolphins and as we say
every week the Dolphins are trying to do
this they wanted to lose the Bengals
however this is not an accident we're
gonna fix the Bengals in the next
segment so we'll hold off on talking
about them but the Dolphins
rose and looked very very bad this past
week he did benched I I know that we a
lot of us liked Josh Rose and I I didn't
have him quite as highly as some other
folks did I think he was QB 3 for me in
that class if I remember correctly but
it's so hard to get into valve him but
yeah yeah I did see a quote from a I
think it was a coach and they were like
an opposing coach it's like even when
the offensive line does their job and
like he gets the ball out it doesn't
look good it's like yes the offensive
line is bad but you have to evaluate
Rosen the way you evaluate him is by ok
when things are right in front of him
evaluate those throws even if you want
to which we've talked a lot about that's
what we do at college you know you you
can't evaluate every throw because so
much of its horizontal and not Pro style
so you try to evaluate pro level throws
with rosin right now when you do that
it's still not looking good so I like in
change we got about 10 weeks of football
left I think right now you have to think
the Dolphins are gonna stick with the
plan to draft a quarterback oh they're
definitely gonna draft a quarterback I
mean the fact that they bench Josh Rosen
for Ryan Fitzpatrick means that they're
not invested in this guy they never gave
him a fair chance anyway considering
they traded away their franchise tackle
it's laughable when you see the play
call for two points it's a win the I
mean this team has no idea what it's
doing let's just call it what it is I
don't care that they have no players the
coach has no idea what he's doing
yeah I mean if you're benching Josh
Rosen it tells you everything you need
to know that you're not interested in
having him at all you know they're gonna
get another chance next year and I hope
Brian Flores makes good on it by having
a real football roster but whether he
has one or not
this team looks completely lost and on
the positive side of things Terry
McLaren was the best player on the field
in that game he's my pick for Offensive
Rookie of the Year right now if you want
to talk some positives for that
Washington team coming off a tough week
where they had to adjust to having a new
coach in there doing things a little
different working what they appears to
be a lot harder in practice right now
it's good for them to get a win get some
momentum because that's a team that has
drafted a lot of talented young players
over the years and you'd like to see
them develop along the way all right
buddy let's take a break we come back we
have Jim naggy
executive director of the Reese's Senior
Bowl talking about what he's seen on the
road this year and also getting y'all
hyped for the upcoming senior ball down
in Mobile Alabama all right we got our
good friend Jim naggy executive director
of the Reese's Senior Bowl on with us
today
Nags we miss you buddy I add the weather
today in Missouri it feels very mobile
and it's like ah I can't wait I've been
looking at air B&B s over the weekend we
are so ready to get back down there and
start watching football with you it's
coming fast
I made the mistake last year buying
these countdown clocks and putting them
up all over town and bars and
restaurants and now every time I see one
it's like clicking down on me and it's
making me give me a cold sweat but it's
coming fast but we're excited about it
Jim let's just get right to it and start
with the good stuff that the people want
what do you think the best player is
you've seen in person this year gosh
it's hard for me not to say Joe Burrell
right now Jerry going off being a being
at the Florida game this past weekend
but you know I would say Javon Kinlaw is
in that conversation
Raekwon Davis at Alabama's in that
conversation so sweet seen a lot of good
players but you know just just coming
off that 21 is 24 the other night
against Florida Joe burrow really
impressive I didn't pay him to say that
I just want to point that out that
that's you two are in this together I'm
not fooled not just like what do you
think of his receiving corps I mean I
know Jamar chase is way too young for us
to begin talking about but guys like
Justin Jefferson I mean I feel like
they've also stepped up as well how much
of that is because of Joe Brady how much
of it's because like they finally have a
competent quarterback in jobber oh yeah
I think Brady's doing a great job at
that offense I think that you got to
give Joe burrow a lot of credit he's
made a significant jump as a player I
thought I thought when I saw him over
the summer you know he would be in like
that third fourth round range kind of
where you know Jared Stidham fell last
year and Ryan Finley I thought you know
he was a guy that you take a shot and a
third of the
or you feel good about him being your
backup and then you know if you
eventually hit on a win with starter
you're happy with that you know maybe
develop into that and he's really you
know he's really tightened up his
accuracy he's got a better arm than I
gave him credit for so now he's you know
he's probably in that that conversation
where teams are going to be looking at
him to be their starter you know I said
this before I think that you can make it
make the case that he's the most
improved player in the country
you know last dress off that was Josh
Allen at Kentucky I think this year is
Jo burrow and you know the reason I'm a
big big believer in Jo is just spending
time with him as the man in camp this
summer and just being around him and
watching him around his peers and then
watching him as a game the other night
like he really you know I posted
something on Twitter about it but I do
think he's got that whatever the it
factor is I think he's got it
I'm just watching how teammates respond
to him and and my interactions with him
he's he's definitely the type of kid you
can tell grew up around football you
know it's dad's a coach and I'm just
kind of got that guy's guy's quality in
total throwback guys to physicians so
yeah big big big believer and Jo we'd
love to get us down here to mobile yeah
I don't blame you and I think this is
the first week coming off that kind of
performance where everybody believes
this LSU team is for real and a lot of
that is because of the quarterback this
seems like the first week everyone has
him in the first round no matter what
and it kind of reminds me a couple years
ago Carson Wentz was that fringe
first-round quarterback and then after
the Senior Bowl it seemed like he was a
top-five lock do you think it's safe to
say that Jo Burrell looks like a
first-round quarterback right now yeah I
do and I think that kind of like Carson
I remember when I was working for the
Seahawks you know we really weren't in
the quarterback game but we still
interviewed every player so we had
Carson up to our room all the scouts
were up there and usually there's a
bunch of players in the suite that we
used to get and Carson was up there by
himself and he just he took over the
room you know like you're just the
person he such as such an awesome
individual and I just I'm feeling Joel
will do the same thing down here the
more team spend time around Jo burrow
the higher his stocks gonna go because
teams are gonna want this guy to be the
quarterback
yeah Joe Burrell looks absolutely
amazing and and I'm glad you mentioned
Javon Kinlaw because I felt like there
were name he was a name over the summer
the people kind of forgot about him but
he has been unstoppable and I think a
big game like South Carolina beating
Georgia it's gonna put him a little bit
more on the radar but this is actually a
really good senior d-line group which is
something we don't see very often with
with kianlawl with Derrick brown with
Raekwon Davis those guys going back to
school how good is that for you how good
is that for them in the NFL the
recruiting part is getting them down
here and convincing them that they have
something to gain and I think they do I
think with with all the interior
defensive linemen the biggest question
is going to be do they have pass rusher
ability and can they stay on the field
all three down if they don't well then
you're you know there's there's a pretty
big drop-off where you're gonna get
drafted so to me you know olan Uihlein
one-on-ones are definitely a drill
designed for defense to win and for
those guys to come down here and show
the teams that they've got that pass
rush ability to be big you know that's
going to be my selling point to those
guys but respected Javon I mean he's
really he's another guy the case study
and why you should come back for your
senior year because had he come out last
year you know probably would have been a
date later date to God I would I would
think based off off last year's tape but
he's got some manchild qualities to him
I mean he's got stuff you can't coach
and he dropped it he dropped a
significant amount of weight this
offseason you know he's really focused
yeah but he had a child in the offseason
and that just usually make guys go one
or two ways one it can kind of consume
them and and take their focus or it can
really you know tighten them down and
really and really make them focused on
football because they need to provide
and that's what it's done for Javon
talking to the guys in South Carolina
about a month ago when I saw him play
Bama they said that he's he's a like a
different guy when it comes to you know
just all the preparation and being all
in and working like he needs to work and
so now you're seeing all those tools
come out I mean he is really explosive
he can run he's long
he's disguised the limit I mean I think
Javon kinloch just scratching the
surface one more specific player I
wanted to ask you about I was lucky
enough to get out for a pac-12 game when
USC came to Washington and I'm just so
impressed without this Washington
program reloads in the secondary after
losing corners and safeties in the first
three rounds year after year and one guy
because he's probably about five nine
180 but he always makes plays as Miles
Bryant have you seen anything from this
Washington secondary not just regarding
the Senior Bowl but overall talent
watching their offensive whether
watching their offensive tape as we
speak this morning and in man they're
off they're not to get you off track or
offensive lines really got to try Adams
Jacob Ethan just sits back there and and
you know it's unbelievable how much time
he's got but but might not miles Brian's
a really good player we're watching him
yesterday it's gonna come down to size
and speed you know he's he's one of
those guys he's a really good football
player but he's under five eight
verified ok so I know they list him at
five nine but he's actually in the five
seven and you know he's just not a very
big person and he and he's you know not
overly fast so I think those things are
gonna hurt where he gets drafted but
that's not to say he's not going to be a
good player at the next level it's kind
of like you know last year Tyler Rapp
ran for 75 and you didn't see that on
tape you saw a guy that could really
close and get to the football but at
that time speed kind of hurt Tyler and
you end up going in the second round I
think that that the measurable stuff
will affect Myles but he is a he's a
really good player the guys in the
office here you know asked me what how
did you compare to Buda Baker and you
know Buda with similar Buddhists the
Buddha's not the biggest guy either but
just a really good football player so
coach Peterson's done an awesome job
recruiting up there and and not just
recruiting they really that's one of the
best developmental programs in the
country they they really bring guys in
and develop them so that secondary fun
to watch and that offensive lineup in
Washington is uh it's fun to watch too
you mentioned your staff and I think
that's one really cool thing that you do
especially for guys who are either
taking a year off the NFL or for younger
guys who are looking to get into
scouting which we have a lot of and our
listeners so the internships that you
guys do or just the the scouting
assistance that you have that's really
it feels to me at least like something
that you changed when you came over when
Phil savage departed how how important
or how much of your vision for the game
is that where you're almost becoming
like a minor league for some of the
scouting departments well Phil did have
some young guys in the office that went
on to get jobs in the league so we're
really just trying to continue that in
the office where we've done it a little
differently is the guys on the road and
you know hiring guys that are in between
jobs you know really trying to I got to
do them as a service to the profession
because you lose your job in football
it's not because you're not good at what
you do most the time it's because you
just end up and use your team as a bad
year so you know given guys kind of a
soft landing spot while they're out of
football for a year keep them active
keep them going to games on the weekend
you know they're seeing GM's they're
seeing decision-makers at games those
guys know that these guys are motivated
to work so you know all four guys that
worked with us last year three of them
got jobs in the NFL one got a job up in
the CFL he actually turned down an NFL
job for a CFL job and now we've got six
we've got six on the road this year and
and in many big house jobs both our guys
went on to the Raiders and the Falcons
and it's just it's a good way to give
back to the profession you know it is
this the professions been great to me
and anything I can do to to help guys
you know that I worked with on the road
for years and then and then the next
generation you know kind of paying it
forward and training these guys and
getting them ready if I feel like I need
to do it so with it being your second
year as the executive director or second
full season here was there anything you
went back to last year and said hey
we're gonna do this differently this
year or any additions what kind of
changes have you made during your
evaluation process this year yeah I mean
we really step back and kind of self
scout ourselves and it started with last
year's roster you know we had 90
three guys drafted in 91 ended up making
53 man roster is opening day but there
was some Duras misses in there too we
looked you know really where you go back
and look to the guys that didn't get
drafted well why weren't they picked and
how can we do that better the position
groups that really stuck out was wide
receiver you know calling around the
league I called around it you know spent
a couple months just randomly calling
teams every couple days and asking why I
got why they thought guys didn't go and
we had eight receivers not get drafted
last year you know and a lot of it was
you know feedback was Jim it was just a
bad there's a bad wide out class but you
know what really came out of that with
special teams
you know guys were good receivers like
David sills from West Virginia good
receiver but you know teams just didn't
see a guy that could help them on
special teams right away needed another
year in the weight room so we're really
taking that new account this year with
the receiver position guys that have
returned ability legit legit return
ability and or special teams coverage
stuff so just you know those sort of
things on the board and then and then
you know just procedurally and how we're
doing things on the scout again just you
know just focusing in more on on our
game and focusing in some more things on
our report writing so we can be more
streamlined in the office but yeah and
hopefully we feel way we would we feel
way further ahead so you know I took the
job June of 18 in place so we went into
last year season with a with a blank
board we had no we had seen any players
really and now going into the year we've
seen all four hundred and seventy five
players on our watch list so now it's
just we're going through the fall tweak
and we're not it's just like an NFL team
we're not you know moving guys way up
and down the board you know we're just
you know we're being able to move guys
up and down a little bit based off their
play this year but we're just we're just
wait further ahead you mentioned you
know last year even at being your first
year but last year was actually like a
legendary Senior Bowl crop and a sudden
you and I've talked about not on the
show before but just the amount of first
rounders was something you know I've
been doing this job for nine years I've
never seen that much talent end up in
the first round from the Senior Bowl and
there were guys you know like Titus
Howard I went down there and was like
yeah I don't have a round one on this
guy think he might be a round two player
he works his way up you know it's and
you know I know it wasn't your class but
like Marcus to have import the year
before but it felt like last year you
had so many of those players who you
were really at least you know because of
the media site I think you were really
the first to have some of these players
of in round one so how how hard is it to
look at this year and say oh man we're
gonna have to get nine first rounders or
how many ever you all end up with last
year on the field again this year
you know we had ten and you always want
to get better so that's that's you know
that's the point but going into the week
it'd be hard you know I thought Daniel
Jones was the first rounder
I thought Montez Sweatt was the first
rounder I thought Andre Dillard had a
chance and Guerra Bradbury but there is
like you know five or six of those guys
that legitimately played their way into
the first round you know LJ Collier
you know you said Titus power Darnell
Savage I mean those guys were guys that
came down here is probably you know
somewhere on day two some of you know I
even think Titus could have gone on
early day three but came down here and
you know really kicked butt for a few
days and proved to him and and I just
give them all the credit because they
you know they were they were going to
get taken on probably day two anyway a
lot of guys in previous years would have
would have listened to an agent or
listened to a family member and and sat
out and just went to the combine but you
know those guys all came down here to
compete and play football and that's I
got told them that's what the NFL wants
to see I mean I've been a part of teams
that you know like drafted guys off the
combine and what guys were doing in
short and made a lot of mistakes that
way so I think the league has realized
that you know that hey let's get back to
football and what these guys doing in
helmets and pads and not so much you
know the other day underwear Olympic
part of it so give it a give credit to
the players and hopefully you know the
hope is that this year's class saw that
success saw forty guys in the first
three rounds come down here and in ten
first rounders where they saw some of
these guys help themselves and they see
the value in our game jiminee small
school even FC
kind of guys already jumping out to you
yet or is it too early for that no I
know that's a good question you know
that's when I say we're ahead that's
where we're way ahead so nice you know
we identified a bunch of these guys over
the summer and we were able to build
those guys into our schedule for the
fall and making sure we go see these
guys live whereas last year guys were
just popping up you know we're getting
phone calls about Cory Valentine that
you know you know out in Kansas and
going to see Cory you know Cory play and
we and it really was tough from a
scheduling standpoint you know to in the
middle of the fall kind of to break from
your schedule and make sure you get a
guy into Washburn you know yeah it's
over the summer you know some of the
small school guys Kyle Duggar is always
the name that comes up I know he's been
a hot guy counting on social media
lately but you know these six - he's 222
pounds and ran for four for one so he's
at the d2 level he's an absolutely
dominant player and he sticks out I mean
that's that's what you need to try to
get that across to some of these small
school players and their families and
their coaches is that you know if you're
playing at that level that you really
have to stand out you really have to be
a dominant player and Kyle is that guy
you know he's he's had a few games this
year where he's had multiple touchdowns
every time well because he did as a
returner but even after interceptions
you know you watch it he's like a man
among boys no one wants to tackle him so
you know the feedback from the NFL teams
is that you know we've got to see him in
mobile because it's just hard to give a
proper evaluation based off you know
where he's playing right now because
he's just he's so much better than
everyone so he would be a guy Adam
Troutman at the tight end at date and we
saw a couple weeks ago live for the
first time and he had four touchdowns in
the first half my gosh our Scout was
double-dip in that day Brian Adams and
he was like well I'm you know I've seen
enough at halftime he scored four
touchdowns he was rolling over to Ohio
State to catch a night game but so
Troutman is converted quarterback really
twitchy crisp route runner great hands
he had a one-handed touchdown this week
that was just incredible but makes a lot
of contested plays so really intriguing
guy in the past game
so and James Robinson the running back
at Illinois State is a big 220 pound
dude that is really patient runs hard
and good after contact so yeah that's
that's been a great part of having a
staff in place for a year is identifying
those small school guys early before we
let you go against something you know we
have the pleasure of talking to you a
lot when we're not on the podcast is
something that we have talked about is
that mobile is a great destination for
football fans and someone again III
think this will be my tenth Senior Bowl
this coming year which just means I'm
getting old but you know we talk a lot
about it on the show that like this is
our favorite trip that we take because
we get we get to all come together with
a lot of our listeners a lot of our
readers but all we do is sit in the
stands in 60 degree weather and watch
football you don't have to have a press
pass to sit in the stands to watch
football and then we go out and drink at
night and eat really good seafood how
much is that part of where you guys want
to take this game in terms of it's a
very affordable fun destination for
people that love college football in the
NFL Draft no I appreciate you asking
that question because you know that was
spending spending time in Nashville for
the draft it was an eye-opener for me
you know when you're working for a team
in the NFL you're worried about building
a football team and you're not worried
do it you're like you're not worried
about what goes on and in and around the
draft but to see all those people in
Nashville was an eye-opener because I
truly believe what we have here in
Mobile is such a great event in terms of
if you're really a football person if
you love the dress and you love football
like you said you can go to practice and
sit in the stands you know or go down by
you know go by the field and stand 10
feet from these drills or come over to
the hotel and last year you could have
taken a selfie with Gardner Minshew or
Daniel Jones or one of these guys or
Baker the year before or Terry Maclaurin
I mean all these guys are blowing up now
you could have had access to those
players and then at night like you said
you know stumble into a bar and see you
know John Schneider or you know Mike
Brey Bowl or Matt Miller Connor Rodgers
or you know like have a beer with guys
that you know football guys so if I'm a
fan like that's a really that's a really
cool week so what what we need to do I
that's why I appreciate you asking the
question we just need to get the word
out to fans and what what this week is
and how awesome it is if you're real
football person we're building things
out where haven't we did a Leadership
Conference last year on Thursday we're
going to have that again Gary Vee is
going to be our keynote speaker at that
Wow
Friday night this year Friday night this
year we're doing a street party and
parade with the players they're gonna
they're gonna throw autographed
footballs to the kids and we're going to
have you know bands and then we got a we
got a pretty cool musical act lined up
for a concert downtown here free concert
so downtown is going to be packed so
we're just trying to create you know
similar to what Nashville did with with
a lot of with a lot of adult beverages
and live music
trying to make this more of a party
atmosphere because the football part has
always been here now we're just trying
to build in that party atmosphere to
give people you know three good days
come down here and blow it out blow it
out around the game well I can't wait
it's gonna be awesome I mean we're more
excited than ever for this year and I
know it's gonna be a good time and as
always Jim we appreciate your time so
thanks so much for coming on I know
we'll talk to you very very soon because
we'll be nagging you about more players
and about two to three weeks so thanks a
lot man we appreciate it
no no I appreciate you guys and first
invites will go out that first week in
November so maybe we can perform Agins
then that's perfect then thanks Jim
thanks buddy yep see you man enjoy it
it's time to fix the Cincinnati Bengals
in holy God do they need our help so
hope you're listening bill Tobin and
everyone else because we are gonna try
to hook you up and fix this team that is
Owen six right now they only projected
number two overall pick in the NFL Draft
the Dolphins right now projected to have
the number one they have all their own
original picks no trades that we have to
mention at least as of yet as a team
that is projected to have 46 million
dollars in cap space but guys like AJ
Green Trey Hopkins darkess Denard Andrew
Billings John Jerry Andre Smith they got
some free agents coming down the pike of
course next year they get first rounder
Jonah Williams back who's out this year
with a knee injury so Connor
man there's a lot to try to figure out
and I want to try to be realistic I'm
not just gonna say like oh well
Newton and Jadeveon gonna want to go to
Cincinnati
yeah and that those things just don't
really happen on this level and I think
Cincinnati is not a team that's
necessarily looking to make all their
splashes through free agency with Duke
Tobin there I think you like you said
Matt losing Jonah Williams before
training camp even began was just
absolutely devastating for this team as
the Zach Taylor era begins but let's
start with just the drafts fear of where
this team currently stands like you said
they're projected to pick number two
overall I believe tank athan because the
strength of schedule does have them at
number one do we think this is a team
that can possibly finish worse than the
Dolphins yes there's possible right you
want to if you are a Bengals fan I want
to make that right we're yeah no you
absolutely want to but God like I I
guess anything is possible but the
Dolphins are I mean are so low right now
like points scored they're awful on
points allowed I think the bengals at
least have some talent especially once
AJ Green gets back Andy Dalton's a hell
of a lot better than anyone the Dolphins
are gonna put out at quarterback so I'd
be like the Bengals will accidentally
lose a game or two along the way which
really does I mean it's gonna affect
everything because where I would start
with the draft is to draft to up but if
they don't have the number one pick
that's not happening and then we get
into a conversation of okay do we look
at a jobber oh here at number two
overall I'm Joe burrows biggest fan
whose last name isn't borough and I
think that might be a little bit too
high in a draft class that also features
chase young and Jerry Judy with AJ Green
being a free agent who I think it's
unlikely for him to return at this point
or at least not expected I think you
have to consider Jerry Judy even though
you don't have your quarterback yet and
then I you have to look at chase young
even with there being a lot of good pass
rushers and free agency whether that
Shack bear it whether that's Jadeveon
Clowney whether that's Whitney Merciless
I think you have to look at chase young
there if you're drafting number two
overall so when I when I start this is
like okay I'm as a mock draft tool would
be my pick if he's not available it
would be chase young invited vice versa
you know I mean if if two is there
that's the guy obviously
yeah I think so I think when you look at
this number one these teams play week 16
that might be the to a bowl the ball
dolphins burst the Bengals so when it
comes down to it that game is gonna be
very key when evaluating how this team
restructures like you said to is the
ideal situation as a pick I think if
you're picking second yeah I'm with you
Matt I don't see how you pass on chase
young if you're the Bengals in this new
era with a young coach you need talent
right now a premium talent on the edge a
game-changing pass rusher that we
believe has the ceiling to be that miles
Garrett Khalil Mack kind of player I
don't see how you could pass on that and
we are gonna get to a full a four-round
mock draft at the end of this but I
think that's where this conversation
starts and let's talk about their free
agents because they do really have a key
one here in AJ Green that his name has
been tied to all kinds of rumors he has
not been healthy these last two seasons
here I don't think he brings back a
first-round pick anymore although I know
a lot of people disagree I think he
brings back a day to pick now I will say
this for a Bengal seem that the season
is over and you should be trying to tank
if he comes back healthy and you can
move him for a day to pick considering
he's a pending free agent you have to do
it you have to move him so that's where
the selling starts for me out of this
pending free agency crop they have no I
agree I think you have to try to sell to
uh excu two of my goodness I'm reading
my own notes here I think you absolutely
have to try to sell aj green whether
that's to the 49ers Eagles the Patriots
you really should not Karras the Bengals
this isn't a time to be picky and say
we're not trading you to the AFC I would
even trade him to the AFC North because
you're just trying to start over at this
point so when I that's what I look at
this like man you have very few assets
you have to try to get something out of
the ones that you do have especially
because of his impending free agency so
I would flip him I agree he's not
bringing back a first-round pick on an
expiring contract maybe a round three
pick on that expiring contract with a
day three type pick kicked in there to
add some value so that is where I would
start it Connor when you look at the
guys that they need to resell
we both actually agree here I think you
have to try to keep trained Hopkins yeah
or you're going to the market to sign
someone in the middle okay Billy price
you know missed his rookie year so we're
still watching him develop but that this
offensive line is absolutely terrible so
finding okay there's a couple good
pieces here we got to try to keep those
it's awful and we're gonna talk about
that offensive line as we get closer to
the mock draft at the end of this but
for a free agency's sake listen if they
lose Hopkins you should go out and pay
someone like JC Treader from the Browns
within your division that has played at
a high level this year I think you know
this is an infrastructure that is going
to have a young quarterback in place
very soon you can't have this current
offensive line in front of that player
especially in this system now they were
very proactive in the draft to get two
very good blockers one being a left
tackle and Jonah Williams who's gonna be
back the other being a blocking tight
end your sample who I Matt you said it
they drafted him much earlier than
anyone expected but if drew sample could
do anything
it is definitely block but yeah you got
to tie up the interior after getting
those guys and those guys need to be
healthy so I think that's where you got
to read the reefs on Hopkins go out and
get a center the best one on the
external market will be Treader looking
at you know Andrew Billings I'd bring
him back I think you would agree right
yeah I loved Andrew Billings I was
surprised he fell as far as he did in
the draft to I think he is the type of
guy you want to try to keep on this
roster yeah because it's not a complete
teardown so I look at him and say yeah
that is someone I would like to keep
building around but then I would go out
and free to see with that 46 million I
would try to get a Whitney Merciless or
a Shaq Barrett you're probably not
getting Jadeveon Clowney I I don't I
still don't think Chris Jones gets away
from the Chiefs so I think you're in
this secondary market we're being
realistic we've seen this with the
Browns I think the bengals to this point
- you're going to have to overpay a
little bit for free agents they can do
that and they can do it aggressively by
getting to the secondary market instead
of going after the top-tier guys so that
would be my moves I would keep Billings
I'll keep Hopkins and then I would look
at merciless or Shak Barrett as the
Freitas I'm gonna sign actually I'm okay
with this
secondary that the Bengals have it's a
little bit young but I like William
Jackson I like Dre Kirkpatrick and in
the draft I think you can look to
bolster your cornerback three or
cornerback for position yeah and two
free agency ideas I had is you kind of
sticking with the outside linebacker
although he's not as much of a pass
rusher maybe you can get Kyle van Noy
from New England I know free agents from
New England don't perform as well once
they leave New England but Vannoy man
noise really resurrected his career
since arriving in New England I think he
could do a lot of different things in
this Cincinnati front and I don't think
he'll cost you top dollar one more who
has been one of the best past catching
tight ends in football this year would
be Austin Hooper so Tyler Eifert just
can never stay healthy I think it also
goes back to Carl Lawson as talented as
he is is another guy that struggles to
stay on the field consistently so maybe
get somebody for your front seven as you
alluded to Matt get a pass catcher for
the future young quarterback in a guy
like Hooper let's talk about the NFL
Draft for this team because that's where
the bulk of the rebuild is gonna be done
in Cincinnati yeah it is if this is a
team that is wisely building through the
draft and I think that's the plan when
you bring even a young guy like a Zach
Taylor as head coach you want to go
through the draft my first four picks I
know I said earlier it's either to uh or
chase young that's the first pick for
them again if they have the first
overall pick
it's two if they don't as chase young
and then it's a trickle effect in round
two let's assume you get your
quarterback whether it's to uh or Joe
burrow it's assumed quarterbacks gonna
be a priority in some way it's not gonna
be Andy Dalton in round two I would go
back to that interior defensive line
and go after a guy and I had him all my
notes before we talked to Jim naggy Yvon
Kinlaw who absolutely has wrecked people
this year getting after the quarterback
he and Andrew Billings working side by
side I think that's a great foundation
in a 4-3 defense Kinlaw is I mean he has
power he has quickness Gino Atkins is
getting older so I that's where I look
like man we could really improve the
middle of this defensive line by going
after a guy like Kinlaw well I think
it's a plug and play starter round three
you're not gonna replace AJ green with a
third-round pick but that's okay because
you have Tyler Boyd who I really like
you have we're finally seeing some
flashes from John Ross so there's there
are some guys here to like but I would
go after receiver this is our tile and
Wallace fits in for me I've seen some
round one talk for me he's round three
you know he's not the fastest guy he's a
little bit skinny but I do like his
route running I like his contested catch
ability a lot actually
with contested catches you just worry
about speed and separation but I think
Thailand Wallace in round three could be
a starting level wide receiver at the
next level and then someone you
mentioned earlier again I swear to God I
did this before the show started I don't
know where trace met this guy excuse me
you said Troy Adams I have Trey Smith my
goodness I don't know where Trey Smith
will slot in playing guard at Tennessee
eva's guy who's a five star tackle
basically back in high school but I like
Trey Smith what I've seen it guard this
year at Tennessee I think someone with a
lot of potential so I have around four
great on him right now
I'm sorry spoiler alert not Trey Adams
Trey Smith
but listen Trey Smith it's all about
health I mean the fact that you can get
him on the field he's a great player
when he's on the field so that's a
sneaky sneaky good ad for the interior
man I really like that pick I'm gonna
start mine off with basically what you
said with to or chase young that's how
this thing dictates whether they're
picking number one or number two another
low key thing in all this is if you get
to a and you're fully committing to him
playing right away you can cut Andy
Dalton and save 17 million dollars and
that goes back to the free agency pool
we talked to you to go get a Shaq
Barrett to go get a Whitney Merciless to
go get an Austin Hooper to add to your
offensive line so you talking about 46
million dollars or you're talking about
upwards of over sixty million dollars
the Bengals can have some money to work
with to really rebuild this team the
right way the coaching staff and front
office wants to back to the mock draft
ture chase young number one or number
two overall round two this is the top of
round two Trey Adams you heard Jim naggy
talk about him
when I saw Troy Adams against USC I
thought he might have been the best
player on the field that day he's a
powerhouse tackle he would be a top ten
pick but he struggled with injuries and
surgeries throughout his career now I
know Veera Bengals fan a Washington
player with surgery scares you a little
bit after going through the John Ross
experience
but I think Trey Adams is healthy and I
think in round two if you have a
potential franchise tackle on the board
you take that risk man him and Jonah
Williams Jonah on the Left Trey on the
right you build up this interior Joe
Mixon in the backfield Zach Taylor knows
how to scheme up the run this can be a
punch you in the face kind of team down
the line round three
Donovan peoples Jones meet Matt mean you
always think the same when we do mock
drafts and we don't do them together you
went for the trenches in round two
you went for the trenches you went for
the quarterback in round one I did the
same thing round three wide receiver
Donovan peoples Jones has not had the
chance to showcase his talent in
Michigan because of the offense because
of the quarterback he is number one wide
receiver potential he hasn't been able
to show it in college I think he could
be a steal in round three if he does
fall that far
round four and what you said going back
to the secondary maybe you look for a
day three a day to piece the ad here I
love Darnay Holmes at a UCLA that
program has been a terror they haven't
done him any favors
he's a great great student of the game a
great athlete a good player that once
again one of those guys flying under the
radar that can really bring you a lot of
value to his secondary and you don't
have to spend a premium pick on him yep
that is how we fix the Cincinnati
Bengals I want to know how you guys
would fix this team yeah especially if
you're a fan of this ballclub tweet us
at stick to football this could be your
iTunes review your spot wherever you
leave your food review Spotify stitcher
wherever it might be let us know how we
did and let us know what team you want
to see next week when we start fixing
these ball clubs let's get into some
draft on draft questions buddy I know
this one is near dear to your heart may
be asked how does Lynn Bowden's move to
quarterback get viewed by NFL teams and
Scouts I always say the more you can do
the better yep and so I think that's
where we're at with this is okay this is
a good thing he's showing his the fact
that he's a team player he's showing his
athleticism his versatility this is a
good thing for Lynn Bowden it's a good
thing for his draft stock and really is
probably the only thing right now
keeping Kentucky somewhat competitive I
mean man they were dad they were down to
the wire here and had to convert their
best offensive player to quarterback now
I believe Bowden played quarterback in
high school so that's why you could see
he can't actually it's
a little bit as you saw in their
weekends their win this weekend I agree
with you bad I said to somebody on
Twitter that asked me actually this this
question has come in quite a few times
that's why we put it in the rundown here
you like this if you're a scout because
it's kind of a selfless move when he's
completely taking away from his great
receiving numbers he's had this year and
saying yeah I'll play quarterback
because it's the only way we can win
ballgames right now he's running the
ball a ton which means he's taking more
hits on his body Bowden is a selfless
player and I think this is a very very
impressive move and he did well he
played really good he really did play
well especially early I mean until they
adapted a little bit he was he was
moving the ball pretty well yeah as a
passer so I think it's good for Lynn
Bowden who I'm not sure yet where I have
him I mean I have a preliminary grade on
him but he's an exciting player for sure
I'm just asset all-around athlete he'll
end up a patriot which is basically with
this course so here's my life our guy is
back dude Anthony Mangal uzo is back
can you guys rank the XFL quarterbacks
for us now that they are on teams I
can't believe I'm about to say this as a
Texas fan I don't know what's happening
to me reuniting Landry Jones of Bob
Stoops is something I'm totally
absolutely here for
I think Landry Jones the best
quarterback in the XFL man ah it's stuff
I don't agree but I do think that
offense will be clicking on all
cylinders I'm excited to watch Cardale
Jones just for the chaos although I
don't think he'll be the best
quarterback
I thought Luis Perez played well in the
a he did he did look good so that's one
that I'm kind of I know Phillip Walker
has had some good games in pre-season
with the Colts at times Matt McGloin has
had some good real life NFL games and
maybe I'm just being a New York Homer
already for the Guardians
it's an it's actually I'll say this Matt
it's a more exciting group than I
expected I think you look at the list
and maybe wish because we're nerds I
knew the names and I'm like these guys
can at least play the position and run
an offense and I think Tyree Jackson
will be in that mix of
- he's still more of a developmental guy
but we know what kind of talent he has
so the XFL I'm a sucker I'll be watching
oh I'll be watching yeah and I was
actually going to say that for me the
second one would have been Louie Perez
just because I thought he looked really
good as an AF quarterback and I think
that's a good thing that we're seeing
here is that we actually are getting
several AAF quarterbacks in the XFL
which if so if you like you know started
to follow a guy there and he didn't get
called up to the NFL well now you got a
chance like you got a chance to continue
watching this guy play so I think
they've done a good job of that uh okay
well if you follow Perez now you still
can
I want Cardale Jones to succeed so badly
because those three games when he was at
Ohio State - in the year he's three of
the most exciting football games I've
ever seen him just like oh that we're on
the third string quarterback now but
it's okay we're still gonna win a
national championship so I'm all about
getting Cardell out there slinging the
ball around just let him just run for
Virts
every single game play and let him throw
the ball down the field it'll be a good
time so the XFL listen we're in you know
stick the footballs in we were in on the
af4 it's very very long life span and
will be the same for the XFL all right
this one from Kieffer congratulations to
Kieffer because he got married this
weekend sorry we couldn't be there buddy
sometimes you got to work you are
stranded on a deserted island which for
NFL head coaches would you want with you
to help you survive he says sorry guys
you can't bring Kyle Shanahan or Bill
Belichick well that would have been my
Bill Belichick go to my first pick
because I fell for it figure out
everything so I would actually I would
want Anthony Lynn I don't know we don't
talk about him a lot because the charges
aren't very good I have so much
confidence than Anthony Lynn being able
to do basically anything he's in shape
he's intelligent like listen I love Andy
Reid I'm not going to a deserted island
with Andy Reid just not gonna know I
mean there's no ingredients to cook
whatever he wants I'm not taking Kliff
Kingsbury because if someone can be
brave us he's too good-looking they
would take him so do you never take the
pretty never ever take the prettiest guy
so Sean McVeigh Anthony Lynn those are
definitely - I wish Gus Bradley were
still a head coach because I would
definitely take him yeah that would be a
really good one
oh man
and Adam GaSe is too crazy yeah I know
he's a hermit he would drive you nuts
Sean McDermott the perfect pick I think
I think Sean McNee doumo
Bill Callahan is a psycho but he's he's
a deserted island kind of wing man
psycho right I'm gonna take Frank Reich
he already has the beard that's a good
pic and he's overcome so much adversity
he's like Josh McDaniels doesn't want
the job here you can have it oh your
star quarterback retires you still be
which eats which I bring Gruden for the
motivation [ __ ] no I yeah him within 30
minutes of being there he's just too
over-the-top
yeah he would get annoying he would
definitely get annoying I love it but he
he would get over the top that was a
good question from Kiefer I really like
that one I'm actually curious cuz I feel
like our listeners are usually like
brainiacs with the explanations of food
they would I know we'd use her this
that's a stick to football throwback
remember the gauntlet oh I missed that
yeah when we get the prospects back on
we'll bring out the gunite yeah the
revised gauntlet be like version 3 or 4
of the gauntlet
all right final question of the week
from our buddy Tyler worden he is a
Dolphins fan so be nice to him as a
Dolphins fan who is fully on board with
the tank for tua train that is a hashtag
tank for tua what are some negatives
about his game that I should be
concerned about well at NFL Draft scout
what are some negatives about to his
game I think the first one is gonna be
the talent he has around him that's
that's what you're gonna automatically
worry about and that there are there are
many times where yet his touch and
anticipation are his best traits but
they're absolutely time for he's
throwing two guys who are already NFL
receivers and they're playing defenses
that just aren't to that level basically
so I think the town around him is a
question he has been banged up
especially the last year I don't feel
like his arm strength is elite it's good
but it's not great which is why you know
excuse me I've said he's more Drew Brees
with that soft touch not so much
you know this home run hitter this
Patrick mahomes or Josh Allen huge arm
so I think that that's a fair question
he's not the tallest guy either I know I
know naggy they measured him at Alabama
pro day he's over 6 foot but under 6
foot one and
we've I think we've seen this you a
baker may feel watch the Niners game he
had trouble seeing over the line and so
with tua you're gonna have that worry
but I do not believe being a left-handed
it should in any way be looked at as a
negative yeah it's just such outdated
and narrow-minded thinking for me when
people tweet me and say well do you have
to make the left tackle the right tackle
no Von Miller and Khalil Mack rush off
the right side of the line you're right
tackle better be pretty good already so
I just don't I don't understand that
line of thinking basically yeah I don't
either I think to uh I'll tell you why
the negatives will come out when he
measures because he's not an overly well
an overwhelmingly big guy and that's not
just Hyades do you think he's gonna be
under 6 1 Matt yeah I think he'll be
like 600 three very Baker ish but I
don't think he's as thick as Baker was
but he can gain the way I personally
have no don't have those concerns I
think the size will be fine
I think he moves very well like you said
touch thrower it's just gonna be he has
to stay healthy because we've seen him
get banged up in the past behind a good
offensive line and in the NFL wherever
you go when you're number one or number
two pick you're gonna be playing behind
a bad one that's just how it goes so the
Dolphins sake they have enough picks
where maybe they can take an offensive
lineman or two while also getting to a
so that's something that you should be
confident but I just think he's smart he
gives a good mindset I think he has all
the talent I don't know we're not gonna
agree to out as this 9'o kind of player
that's not what we're saying here but in
the terms of safer quarterbacks I am
actually a believer that he's a
relatively safe quarterback yeah I agree
I think he is a relatively safe
quarterback without a super high ceiling
but he's so smart and his accuracy is so
good but it goes back to okay well what
do we have over that what are the elite
trace if your elite traits are football
intelligence and touch good that's great
but it can be a little bit scary I think
at times so I I'm still - still my top
quarterback I'm all in on it but I don't
like you said he's not gonna grade out
as any any kind of perfect prospect for
me alright that is our show Connor
mellow and myself we'll be back Friday
morning getting you ready for the
weekend of college football and thank
God were actually all home